Oh
[Music]
you know with the advent of the
commercial space revolution with the
fact that human beings are finally going
to domesticate space travel it's worth
celebrating for once why we want to
explore the heavens to begin with and
Marina Benjamin perhaps has the best
line she says when we dream of space we
dream of transcendence we dream of what
we might become the exploratory journey
that desire to break through boundaries
to probe the perimeters of possibility
to explore the adjacent possible that is
what it means to be human
we didn't stay in the caves says
Kurzweil we didn't stay on the planet
with biotechnology we won't stay with
the limitations of biology in fact today
by leveraging exponentially emerging
technologies we're going to have
computers trillions of times more
powerful navigating spaceships that are
millions of times cheaper taking us to
space Richard Branson's Virgin Galactic
is going to take artists into space
what's going to happen when poets and
artists look down upon the earth what
new reflections that will uplift the
human spirit that will thrust human
consciousness towards the numinous might
transpire when we keep pushing beyond
all limits when we get to Kubrick's
beyond the infinite the placeable dreams
are born through the wormhole down the
rabbit hole it's glorious it's what Neil
deGrasse Tyson says doing what's never
been
before is intellectually seductive
whether or not we deem it practical
it's what we do it's what makes us
cosmic heroes cosmic revolutionaries not
Stooges conscripted to advance a natural
order that kills everyone so let us go
forth
[Music]
[Applause]
you